one of my closest girlfriends is here
jessica Mulrooney who runs Kleinfelds in
toronto and she's helping me yes yes to
the dress
suit style they've come a long way since
their days of styling Rachel Zane now
Jessica Moore Unni is filling the
royalty on just how popular Megan's
fashion influence has become in our
first sit-down interview since the Royal
Wedding Jessica
opens up to Harper's Bazaar calm about
her friendship with the Duchess and why
she tends to stay quiet quote listen
every person has to have a bit of
privacy in their life there are certain
things I hold very dear and secret
there are things I'll never talk about
for sure my life is an open book but
there's always a few secret pages in the
back that nobody will be able to read
this is for the black tie dress love now
I love working with black-tie wedding
although Mulrooney tops fashion on Good
Morning America and has somewhat been
dubbed
Markel's unofficial stylist the mom of
three says she doesn't consider herself
a stylist at all nor does she wanna be
one quote styling is such a small part
of what I do I have like ten jobs people
don't know that I work so much on the
backend of things they think I'm just
dressing people my business is with
brands she's good at it and so is her
royal besties
in fact Mulrooney tells the mag held the
duchess saved one of her favorite
Calgary based brands noni from shutting
down after rocking this trench dress
during her visit to the nelson mandela's
centenary exhibition last July Mulrooney
tells the mag quote it's tough to be a
designer it is really tough to be a
canadian designer sometimes all you need
is that one time break and it'll change
your life adding if you get your item on
a celebrity that's almost like the top
of the top a new way of creating
business
[Music]